non so se avete presente che ci sono
quelle settimane dove fa caldo fa un
caldo bestiale qualsiasi cosa che vi
distrae non vi fa fare quello che dovete
fare quindi nel mio caso di video
nonostante questo mi sono impegnato per
rimanere concentrato e fare i video vi
quando il mio vicino non ha deciso di
iniziare a martellare sul soffitto di
trapanare anche la sua famiglia
proprio quando io dovevo registrare
quindi wow
[Musica]
nonostante questo comunque non è stata
anche la cosa peggiore che è successo
durante la settimana se avete cliccato
sul video lo sapete già perché c'è nel
nel titolo è tutto quindi vi lascio al
video della cosa più bella che è
successa durante questa settimana la
vita è una merda ciao ciao
siamo a casa e ho invitato ecco perché
stiamo mangiando il sushi siamo io che
ecco che è venuto a trovarmi ciao ciao
c'è selena adesso ve la faccio vedere
selena charles elena e poi c'è lui quel
bastardo di merda è tornato è tornato
quel figlio di [ __ ] dobbiamo capire
un attimo una cosa allora perché questa
cazzo di casa infestata da queste merde
da queste merde altri io da quando è
uscito quel video di merda e mi sono
informato tutta roba quindi so che cosa
sono ho letto tutti a sputi genera
questa roba fatica ma scuti gera e c'è
scritto che si mangia i ragni fu scritto
si mangiano i ragni se lo vedi che non
sai mangiare il sushi che non sai aprire
due cazzo di bacchette perché se io
chiedo a lei le bacchette lei le aree
tour non essere in grado di ordinato
anche per lei siamo qua in tre a
mangiare porca vacca si muove cederà
cucina senti tutti volta ho dovuto fare
io votavo dovuto fare io perchè non non
c'era nessuno qua a casa mia
adesso ci sei tu quello stava giallo
bongelli ma la merda a sentirlo nov
il sushi to ammazza quello schifo
iren di una paga l'affitto
l'ultima volta era lì era lì per terra o
che ci ha messo una vita a ucciderla me
la fai fuori per cortesia non con la
scopa serve un arma se tu provi a carla
con quella roba di lei se la prende la
indossa quindi fai altra guarda lido e
se mazza ma queste cose non stanno ferme
si muovono è capito cristo dio che
schifo a runtime madonna come l'altro
regalo
la maxi la massima l'ammazzi eh tu
dietro la uccide arab ucciso tubi caso
sul muro spazzola fuori come ho fatto
l'ultima ma perché devono rompere il
cazzo era passato un mese è una donna
pare proprio possiamo fare in questo
momento
una strada che percorre minuti stato
l'unica da allora si arrampica pisci ma
corre per la 10 libera facciamo la
strada ma poi come l'attrice capitale
che roba di merda dire no no no no no
non tocca una donna che schifo se cade
urlo è da marzo una mazza si calerà
partiva da bossi cav h che schiera ma
che schema io sono solito si stai lì mi
piace come soprammobile dovevo ancora
arredare quel punto stai così non so
cosa devo fare
6 viene verso di me io la videocamera
tutela lancio fai cagare se una persona
schifo ammazzo ti spacco la faccia io ma
sei [ __ ]
ma nella vita che problemi hai tu lavori
è cosa cioè le garantisco che ferma il
zone di merci e su via poi via via via
via a quel garage era ci pensa poi a
bastardo signore e signori
l'uomo della mia vita divento gay si mio
marito io faccio la domanda ovviamente
spazza via tutte le merde
c'è una cosa tra con serena che stupri a
mangiare dopo questa roba non si
scioccato dentro si sono giocati sono
veramente scioccatissima in questo
momento comunque ragazzi prima di
concludere volevo parlarvi di una roba
che molti vi state chiedendo le idee
favi dov'è finito il fare gli sponde
fare risponde per chi non lo conoscesse
è breve tempo fa rispondeva delle
domande in realtà non è che è finito e
che io ho iniziato a fare dei blog
diversi nel senso che il suo blog con la
videocamera vado in giro a volte non
certo vi risponde però se volete farmi
delle domande io faccio fatevi delle
domande con lascia che fa risponde qua
sotto nei commenti insieme alla risponde
ragazzi ogni tanto facevo anche lo scan
taggio dei pacchi ed è da una vita e
mezza che non faccio quindi direi che
possiamo fare uno strappo alla regola e
strappiamo anche i pacchi maghi maghetti
grazie sono anche te le caramelle della
dubbia scadenza secondo me perche e
veramente
vita però tesoro grazie non dovevi
veloci che mi vedi magro però le mangio
io le cose sei tranquillo aveva sentito
io sono un maschio comunque voglio fare
questa precisazione perchè molte volte
mi regalate cose che potrebbero essere
di dubbia provenienza nel senso sono
sono maschio
proprio grazie ho mai detto ma perché
grazie di avermi inviato degli enta i
poster lo appenderò di sala che poi
dovrò spiegarlo a mia madre e come
ultimo c'è anche un poster di fairy tail
grazie minchiate un pacco gigante quanto
a roma c'erano tempo non era così grosso
pacco non fraintendete sempre fraintesi
miei luoghi sempre ai ragazzi spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto concludo
qua anche perché mi ricordo che ogni
volta che scarti bat devo poi mettere a
posto e questa è una cosa che una volta
molto conto ed è per questo che ho
smesso di scarpa dei parchi perché
quando vivevo con i miei ancora mi aiuta
la mia madre a mente la poppa adesso col
cazzo ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come si vive più giusto come mi piace
anche vari social che come descrizione
sarà solo il sì di scrittrici vediamo il
prossimo video e ragazze
[Musica]